[Música]
la crisis política en Perú está
alcanzando niveles muy altos de
intensidad de las manifestaciones
ciudadanas que cada vez congregan a más
personas y cada vez se vuelven más
violentas hasta el momento los choques
entre los manifestantes y las fuerzas de
seguridad peruanas dejan 50 fallecidos y
más de 500 heridos las manifestaciones
comenzaron hace poco más de un mes y se
han extendido a 41 provincias
principalmente en el sur de ese país
suramericano las ciudades de puno cusco
y juliaca han sido los escenarios donde
los choques entre las partes han sido
más violentos qué es lo que reclaman
entonces los ciudadanos puntualmente
piden la renuncia de la presidenta Dina
boluarte la renuncia del pleno del
Congreso peruano y también exigen una
convocatoria inmediata a elecciones
presidenciales y parlamentarias
a lo largo de las semanas los
manifestantes han bloqueado varias vías
regionales también han bloqueado el
comercio e intentaron incluso tomar el
control por ejemplo del Aeropuerto
Internacional de la Ciudad de cusco que
es una importante puerta de entrada de
turistas a Perú también un grupo de
manifestantes partieron en una larga
caminata desde la ciudad de juliaca y
desde otros puntos del Sur del país con
la intención de llegar a Lima la capital
de ese país la presidenta Dina boluarte
Indicó que está abierta al diálogo con
Los Caminantes que han llegado en
diferentes grupos hasta la capital del
país pero la pregunta es que tanto
margen de negociación tiene la
presidenta boluarte con el escenario que
se está presentando actualmente la
inestabilidad en Perú preocupa mucho a
la región y la posibilidad de un nuevo
corte político ante una posible salida
de la presidenta boluarte podría traer
una agudización de la crisis de
gobernabilidad que vive ese país pero
también preocupa por supuesto la
violencia en las calles la muerte de los
civiles y los violentos ataques que hay
en las diferentes manifestaciones así
como esos enfrentamientos que hay con
las fuerzas del orden en las diferentes
marchas que se han visto en varias
ciudades del país es entonces un llamado
a las elecciones una solución a esta
crisis Cómo evitar la impunidad de la
muerte de aquellos que han perdido la
vida en las calles manifestándose
haciendo valer su derecho y elevando su
voz ante los aspectos que con los que no
están de acuerdo con el gobierno actual
en algunos casos a manos de agentes del
orden incluso han muerto algunos
ciudadanos eso está bajo investigación
por parte de una comisión que aprobó el
congreso peruano Hace algunos días atrás
tienen 90 días para dar algún tipo de
respuesta sobre esas muertes a manos
posiblemente de agentes del orden por
eso hoy en el debate de France 24
ponemos entonces la lupa sobre Perú para
analizar la situación allí y para
conversar sobre este tema hemos invitado
a Elizabeth sea ella es directora del
instituto de derechos humanos y
desarrollo también según este análisis
Omar Cairo él es constitucionalista
abogado de la Universidad de Lima y
magíster en derecho constitucional de la
pontificia Universidad Católica de Perú
allí en esta misma institución educativa
allí también ejerce como profesor de
derecho constitucional a nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
hacen parte de este debate pueden dejar
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook y también en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios se las recuerdo rápidamente
numeral el debate f24 todo pegado todo
junto no olviden también que todos los
contenidos del programa también están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Elizabeth desde la Ciudad de Lima
Elizabeth Gracias por estar con nosotros
hoy aquí en el debate de France 24 y un
punto para entender un poco la situación
allí en Perú siendo la presidenta
boluarte ex vicepresidenta de Pedro
Castillo que fue destituido hace ya
algunas semanas es supuestamente el
gobierno que está en Perú es un gobierno
de izquierda que fue el gobierno que
eligieron los peruanos a través del voto
popular Por qué no hay una sintonía
entre el pueblo peruano y la presidenta
boluarte si es la misma tendencia que el
pueblo ha votado
bueno en primer lugar Muchas gracias por
la invitación que me realizas el día de
hoy efectivamente
Yo he sido una de las grandes típicas de
que con este gobierno de castillo y
comprendiendo el gobierno de Castillo
también a su vicepresidenta Dina
boluarte pero aquí estamos ya dentro de
lo del marco de lo que dicta la
constitución en nuestro país y en
nuestro país nos dice que por su sesión
constitucional pues le corresponde a la
señora Dina boluarte cuando ella ASUME
este esta este encargo lo hace ya en un
contexto de crisis esta crisis se ha
comenzado a desatar no a partir de ahora
esta crisis ya viene incluso desde la
época de Castillo solamente que ha
estado pues como una bomba de tiempo de
manera muy silenciosa en las provincias
y se ha venido a activar por estos
grupos violentistas que han aprovechado
digamos la crisis que Se generó ante la
vacancia de Castillo la institución de
castillo y hoy en día Pues están
utilizando desde mi Modesto entender las
demandas legítimas de estos pueblos para
pedir que la señora boluarte renuncie
cuando hablamos de la sintonía que debe
de tener la señora boluarte con las
provincias yo creo que esto no parte de
la sintonía que la señora Baluarte debe
de tener con las provincias esto parte
de un olvido de muchos años de muchas
décadas que ha tenido que han tenido
nuestros hermanos de las provincias no
por parte de los sucesivos gobiernos y
se ha visto pues como te digo exacerbada
esta esta llamado no de de emergencia
este llamado de de atención por parte de
ellos
En esta en esta situación de la de la
destitución del señor Castillo Y
asumiendo pues ahora Dina boluarte ellos
esperaban Pues de repente que la señora
boluarte de riendas a sus pretensiones
de estos grupos izquierdas Como por
ejemplo la asamblea Constituyente que es
a lo que ellos tienen persiguiendo desde
hace ya mucho tiempo
y paso a darle ahora la palabra a Omar
Cairo para conocer también su opinión
Omar Gracias por estar con nosotros aquí
en el programa La misma la misma
pregunta como Punto de partida porque no
existe esta sintonía entre la presidenta
y su pueblo este gobierno de izquierda
que fue electo por el voto Popular en
Elizabeth toca un punto importante que
es esa realidad que hay entre lo que es
vivir en Lima la capital y la realidad
de lo que es vivir en las regiones en
las provincias en los departamentos de
Perú un tema que vamos a analizar en
unos minutos pero quiero ponerlo de una
vez sobre la mesa Cuál es su perspectiva
Cuál es su opinión por esta falta de
sintonía o o de falta de entendimiento
entre las partes
creo que esta falta de sintonía parte de
un error un error de apreciación
generado por el congreso el día del
golpe de estado indudablemente Jorge
Pedro Castillo en la mañana del Siete de
diciembre da un golpe de estado
televisado donde dice que va a disolver
el congreso y que reorganizará los
tribunales de justicia y además va a
convocar elecciones con facultades
constituyentes esto es un golpe de
estado y desde ese instante en virtud
del artículo 46 de la Constitución él se
convirtió en un gobernante usurpador
perdió la calidad de presidente
constitucional y por lo tanto el cargo
estaba vacío tan es así que las fuerzas
armadas
emiten un comunicado desconociendo
la validez de lo hecho por él él es
capturado antes de que concluya el
trámite en el congreso que en un momento
había voy a precisar Por qué genera la
confusión Y entonces Castillo no ha sido
destituido por el congreso no ha sido
vacado por el congreso castí cuando
cuando termina la votación en el
congreso Castillo ya no es presidente no
era necesario que se hiciera ese trámite
lo que ocurre es que el congreso
Aparentemente lo que quiso fue eh
rentabilizar
el la situación afirmando que que ellos
son los que han depuesto a castillo y
han salvado al país de un gobierno
comunista y todo esto que se que se
venía diciendo pero el hecho es que cada
pierde el poder por haber dado un golpe
de estado y no por decisión
parlamentaria Entonces como dijo
Elizabeth el artículo 115 de la
Constitución Establece que Diana
boluarte debe asumir ante la ante el
impedimento material del presidente que
se produce porque porque se convirtió en
golpista y ASUME pero el mensaje que
llega a las provincias es que el
congreso ha depuesto a Castillo le ha
quitado el poder y le ha entregado el
poder a Dina boluarte el gobierno
entonces por eso se le dice congreso
golpista y ahí Usurpadora y ni golpista
ni Usurpadora
Castillo ha perdido el cargo por dar el
golpe de estado y Dina boluarte ha
asumido porque le correspondía de
conformidad con lo Constitución Entonces
esta imagen que proyectó el congreso
Lamentablemente hasta el día de hoy
genera en buena parte de los de la del
de la población del sur andino la idea
de que ella está usurpando el poder que
había ganado en elecciones Pedro
Castillo gracias a un golpe
parlamentario Entonces es eso creo que
es fundamental por eso hace que la única
demanda que subsiste con solidez al día
de hoy es la renuncia de inagoluarte
porque se considera que está usurpando
el poder lo cual no es cierto
la renuncia de Dina boluarte yo creo
debería producirse por otra situación
qué es lo que ocurrió luego de desatadas
las las protestas Qué es la matanza de
49 personas que con lo que cual
constituye un crimen de lesa humanidad y
la conducta que que asumió ella ante esa
circunstancia todo eso amerita que
renuncie para que la situación política
y social del país se estabilice y se
pueda establecer la responsabilidades
jurídicas y los que causaron este este
esta tragedia que está dando la vuelta
al mundo y avergonzando al país Omar
continuó con usted para hacer la ronda
la inversa a ver a usted le ha tomado
menos de un minuto unos 45 segundos
explicarnos este punto de la
Constitución y ha quedado perfectamente
claro Cuál es el marco legal para
entender Por qué Dina boluarte está en
la presidencia de Perú en este momento
Entonces por qué ha pasado un mes desde
el hecho del golpe de estado del intento
de golpe de estado de Castillo Al día de
hoy y los peruanos no entienden esto que
usted nos acaba de explicar en 40
segundos aquí entonces se está
aprovechando esta crisis esta
confusión este momento de inestabilidad
para profundizar la estabilidad o
inestabilidad Perdón del país por otro
tipo de fuerzas políticas otro tipo de
fuerzas desde el interior del país como
lo ve usted
sí no yo creo que la el el el el el el
móvil actual ya no es tanto eh Dina
boluarte por Usurpadora que todavía lo
todavía así si no la reacción de haber
matado a de haber no matado ya sino de
haber eh generado con la respuesta
policial y militar la muerte de 49
personas Eso es lo que nardeces en estos
momentos del sur andino por eso es que
están viniendo a Lima a pedirle a pedir
que salga del cargo por haber o cometido
o permitido esa matanza claro bueno Yo
lo decía en la introducción Elizabeth
hay una comisión que fue votada por el
congreso peruano para investigar estas
muertes de ciudadanos a lo largo de esta
semana en las diferentes ciudades del
sur de el país entendiendo la la
división de poderes allí en Perú con
todo el problema político que tienen se
puede confiar en este tipo de comisiones
se puede confiar en este tipo de
investigaciones allí en Perú para llevar
a cabo este tipo de hechos y el estado
peruano está en capacidad de responder
dado las condiciones en las que está que
es un estado que cada Tantos meses está
renovando el presidente está la
capacidad de responder si en si llegado
el caso de la conclusión de esta
investigación el estado fuera culpable
bueno en primer lugar yo siempre he sido
de la posición que cuando estamos
hablando de posibles violaciones a
derechos humanos desde mi punto de vista
no corresponde politizar este tipo de
hechos formando comisiones
investigadoras porque aquí la labor
principal de esta investigación la tiene
el Ministerio Público y nosotros tenemos
que confiar en las instituciones el
Ministerio Público está impuesto para
garantizar justamente la legalidad de la
investigación Y tenemos de la mano
también actores Como por ejemplo la
defensoría del pueblo que va a estar
pues actuando permanentemente no
haciéndole el seguimiento no solamente a
la conflictividad social sino también a
la actuación de las instituciones del
estado que tienen que ya accionar en
este momento Respecto a los fallecidos
tanto de los civiles como del policía
que ha fallecido en el contexto de estas
protestas violentas
pero también además hay que tener en
cuenta y aquí Me permito señalar algo y
precisar algo que el doctor Cairo estaba
mencionando Respecto a los crímenes de
lesa humanidad por el cual se estaría
denunciando al gobierno de Dina boluarte
yo creo que acusar al gobierno de
genocidio porque es el artículo 319 el
que se menciona en esta denuncias a
firmar que hay la intención de destruir
a un grupo social y yo creo que esta
figura No calza desde mi punto de vista
ya como abogada desde desde el enfoque
del derecho constitucional en el
contexto de las protestas por qué Porque
Más allá de lo que pueda decir la
Constitución obviamente es la carta
constitucional pero también nosotros
tenemos que guiarnos por lo que está
dándose en la realidad y yo soy de las
personas que me gusta mucho informarme a
partir de las radios regionales de
nuestro país Sería muy bueno hacer el
ejercicio de escuchar las radios locales
de las provincias y ver Cómo es que
estas estas radios están convulsionando
a la población con afirmaciones falsas
como las que ha dicho el doctor Cairo
que efectivamente No aquí ha habido una
usurpación por parte de inaboluarte que
el señor Castillo ha sido tomado preso
por las empresas y las corporaciones e
incluso tenemos activistas de la
izquierda como la Señora Lourdes huanca
que en este momento se encuentra en
Europa donde está dando pues sendas
entrevistas donde afirma que el señor
Castillo está preso injustamente por una
dictadura Entonces yo creo que todo esto
suma a la al caos y a la barbarie que se
viene Desatando en nuestro país eso
también merma la confianza en las
instituciones no en las cuales tienen
una labor que hacer ahora y por supuesto
la también le quita un poco de peso al
gobierno para comenzar a articular un
diálogo que en algún momento tiene que
darse Sí
Omar su opinión sobre esta afirmación
Elizabeth
Sí yo lo que lo que tengo claro es lo
que tiene claro este toda la opinión
internacional y es que y la opinión
jurídica internacional además Qué es el
hecho de que
matar
a un grupo de personas por parte de las
fuerzas gubernamentales militares y
policiales
constituye un crimen de lesa humanidad
esto Esto está esto es un delito según
el artículo siete del estatuto de la
Corte Penal Internacional puede ser
genocidio o no puede tener como
finalidad el Exterminio de un grupo
social cultural político inclusive puede
ser
Y en este caso sucederá genocidio pero
el hecho de haber matado a un grupo
tan elevado de personas en acto de
represión de una movilización es un
crimen de lesa humanidad ahora Quien
tenga la responsabilidad penal eso es
cierto lo que dice la doctora le
corresponde establecer a los tribunales
de Justicia pero no solo los tribunales
de justicia de Perú
si en el Perú hay una investigación
deficiente una absolución mentirosa
entonces cualquier juez de cualquier
lugar del mundo va a poder
procesar a los eventuales responsables
que pueden ser la presidenta los
ministros quienes dispararon y
condenarlos
a a las penas correspondientes Ese es el
punto de la responsabilidad criminal
Pero hay una responsabilidad política
que en el Perú se y en muchos países se
traduce de la manera siguiente la
responsabilidad política la soportan
ciertos funcionarios que ante una
actuación reprochable políticamente
deben perder el cargo sea por decisión
parlamentaria o porque la la el el otro
funcionario superior les quita el cargo
Qué pasó en el Perú cuando en diciembre
entre el 14 al 18 de diciembre se
produjeron 28 fallecidos por la
represión de las protestas
la responsabilidad política no digo que
sean culpables criminalmente era de los
ministros de defensa y del interior qué
debía hacer la presidenta destituirlos
de sus cargos por haber conducido de una
manera tan deficiente esta esta
respuesta que originó veintiocho
fallecidos y que hizo la ministra la
presidenta los mantuvo sus cargos y
premió al ministro de defensa
ascendiéndolo a la presidencia del
Consejo de ministros entonces ahí
empieza a ver por lo menos una
apariencia de consentimiento con lo que
ocurrió Sí y luego menos de un mes
después el nueve de enero se produce una
segunda matanza en un solo día de
dieciocho personas y lo mismo todo lo
que hubo como respuesta de la presidenta
fue pedir perdón y decir que
la responsabilidad era de quienes
causaban la violencia y no de quienes
habían producido este desastre que está
Lamentablemente avergonzando al Perú en
el mundo Entonces que se produjo crimen
de lesa humanidad de eso creo que no hay
duda que la responsabilidad es políticas
no las hizo efectiva la presidenta
también está claro porque no despidió a
nadie de sus cargos eso puede acercarla
a ella a la responsabilidad penal en su
momento Claro porque Recuerden que en el
caso de los crímenes de lesa humanidad
funciona la teoría del dominio del hecho
Alberto fujimori está preso por dos
matanzas en barrios altos y la cantuta
un del año 1991 y el otro en 1992 en ese
caso fujimori no disparó un solo tiro
pero fue el que el que tenía El dominio
del aparato
que realizó esas matanzas claro las
permitió y e igual que que hoy día no
destituyó a nadie Entonces eso genera un
peligro de que se pueda considerar
eventualmente la responsabilidad penal
de la presidenta boluarte cuando sea
expresidenta cuando cuando uno es jefe
de estado eso no puede hacerlo
entonces con este Marco que nos que nos
presentan ustedes dos y con este
escenario ya bastante Claro en términos
jurídicos la presidenta ha ofrecido
diálogo sobre todo con las partes con
los ciudadanos que vienen en esta larga
caminata desde la ciudad de juliaca En
Los Andes peruanos en el sur del país
hasta la capital qué tanto margen de
negociación no de diálogo puede tener la
presidenta entendiendo ya este marco
jurídico que ustedes nos han nos han
explicado y entendiendo ya la situación
de lo que se está presentando
Disculpen Bueno definitivamente
yo no no confiaría tanto en la
presidenta el diálogo Yo entiendo de que
existe a partir de la presidencia del
Consejo de ministros se van a establecer
las mesas de diálogo con las personas
con los representantes de los distintos
gremios que vienen hacia hacia lima para
hacer una protesta se entiende pacífica
no es pacífica y y para poder encontrar
tener puntos de encuentro Porque para
iniciar un diálogo primero es muy
importante la legitimidad de los
interlocutores y es necesario que las
partes que esperan este diálogo pues se
encuentren eh Confort conforme se
encuentren digamos bien de acuerdo con
las personas con las cuales van a
dialogar
yo creo que aquí lo que ha hecho falta y
sigue haciendo falta es una iniciativa
por parte del gobierno de poder tratar
de ofrecerles a estas personas que
vienen del interior al país a nuestros
Hermanos peruanos una agenda pública que
permita en algún de alguna manera
abordar las principales necesidades de
los pueblos más olvidados Yo pienso que
podría ser un buen Punto de partida Sigo
pensando que abundar en en la idea de de
que se ha cometido crimen de lesa
humanidad sin siquiera tener una
investigación preliminar a pesar de que
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos hace muy poco ha dicho en su
misma conferencia de prensa que ellos no
pueden afirmar en este momento tal cosa
porque faltan realizar investigaciones
lo que sí se afirma es que hay
obviamente los los fallecidos han sido
eh asesinados por por disparos de bala
lo que hay que hacer aquí sí es una
investigación pero comenzar a sembrar la
idea lo único que va a hacer es más bien
es asustar más al caos no van a tener
esa disponibilidad del diálogo con el
gobierno que es lo que nosotros queremos
con sus representantes legítimos y que
aquí también intervengan los actores del
acuerdo nacional que se abra el diálogo
con las regiones y que se encuentren a
Los reales interlocutores y no aquellos
representantes que lo que quieren no es
una demanda social o sacar adelante
demanda sociales sino demandas políticas
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos también lo ha dicho y diferenció
ese día que las demandas políticas
tienen un cauce y la demanda social
tiene otra y es el gobierno peruano el
que tiene que estar encargado del manejo
este diálogo garantizando el ejercicio
los derechos fundamentales no en ese
orden de ideas Elizabeth la presidenta
boluarte ha pedido al congreso que
convoque a elecciones anticipadas para
realizar pues estos comicios en ese país
y el congreso pero no ha dado ninguna
respuesta y no lo ha puesto en trámite
es uno de los grandes reclamos que
también tienen los ciudadanos convocar a
unas elecciones para renovar el congreso
y para elegir a un nuevo presidente o
presidenta en este país Aquí Entonces
qué papel entonces juega el congreso que
tampoco da trámite para poder dar por lo
menos una solución por lo menos una
fecha que le garantice a las personas
un día para ir a ejercer un voto de
manera anticipada para tratar de buscar
la solución política y democrática a
esta crisis Totalmente de acuerdo aquí
el congreso está de legitimado El
Congreso en este momento tiene una única
agenda y la única agenda es darle
solución a esta crisis social y política
que se ha desatado en nuestro país
porque ellos son tan peruanos como
nosotros y merecen una respuesta
inmediata por parte de los poderes del
Estado no es posible que en este momento
de acuerdo a las últimas informaciones
que a mí me están llegando porque nos
estamos nutriendo de toda la información
existan bancadas de izquierda en el
congreso que quieran dilatar esta
votación esta segunda votación donde se
tienen que obtener los ochocientos los
ochenta y siete votos para poder decidir
sobre el adelanto de elecciones y
quieran poner como condición la asamblea
Constituyente esto realmente Eso sí es
criminal eso no es responder a la
voluntad popular del pueblo peruano y
eso a mí me parece que sí atenta
directamente con la contra los derechos
de de todos nosotros y realmente eh
Espero que esto sea solamente una previa
posición y que muy pronto desde ya tenga
que dar ya no se puede aplazar más la
fecha y votar de una vez este adelanto
de elecciones porque es lo que está
reclamando el país viendo claramente
esta forma de actuar del Congreso
peruano Ahí es donde uno entiende esa
frase que están gritando los
manifestantes en las calles esta
democracia ya no es democracia pasó
entonces a preguntarle a Omar por la
opinión que usted tiene de el desempeño
del parlamento del Congreso peruano a la
hora de dar solución a este a esta
crisis y
su análisis de esta frase esta
democracia ya no es democracia hay
grietas en la democracia peruana están
las bases de la Democracia peruana que
hay que decir es bastante
nueva si lo vemos desde el punto de
vista político
está empezando a tener problemas en sus
bases
Sí yo creo que yo creo que sí creo que
tiene serias dificultades pero yo quería
precisar algo no estoy introduciendo el
tema de los de los crímenes de lesa
humanidad sino que está presente Los
manifestantes los esgrimen la comunidad
internacional usted puede ver los
titulares de del de la New York Times
desde Guardian todos los todos la prensa
internacional hace alusión no el tema
político de de reclamos por por mejoras
en el agro sino en las muertes entonces
la evidencia de que hay ha habido una
matanza y una matanza es un crimen de
lesa humanidad está ahí por esa razón es
que creo que la solución a la crisis
está en dos posibles medidas
o la presidenta boluarte Aunque
tardíamente
hace efectiva la responsabilidad
política por esas muertes y despide
política me refiero no criminal y
despide al Primer Ministro del que
condujo políticamente esa gestión o ella
renuncia en ese momento creo que el
surandino Se va se va se va a dar cuenta
que las vidas del del de la de la de la
gente que pertenece a su entorno se
respetan de igual manera que se respetan
la de Lima Entonces eso creo que va a
ser muy importante o despedir a la
conducción ministerial que generó todo
esto en términos políticos o que ella
renuncie esos eso es ese es el único
diálogo posible que hay ahora no en este
momento la yo estoy seguro que la gente
no va a venir a decir bueno que que
incrementen el presupuesto que compren
fertilizantes esas cosas no son las que
han movilizado a las personas para
producir la crisis del tamaño de de que
la que la tenemos ahora entonces creo
que
Omar pero pero justamente esta crisis y
retomo la pregunta que le estoy haciendo
para que sea puntual por favor
justamente esta crisis llega porque hay
problemas grietas en las bases de la
Democracia peruana independiente de
todos los problemas y las diferencias
que hay entre lima y las regiones
hay problemas en la democracia peruana
el establecimiento como tal del gobierno
peruano está teniendo problemas de base
que cada vez quedan más en evidencia
pero nadie hace nada para tratar de
mejorarlas
es verdad es verdad y en estos momentos
como decía el Elizabeth hay una dilación
irresponsable del Congreso el congreso
es un lugar de convocar a la segunda
legislatura el primero de febrero lo que
ha hecho es convocarla para el quince y
con una razón con una motivación quieren
aprobar el adelanto de elecciones Pero
antes de eso quieren aprobar una reforma
dos reformas constitucionales la
bicameralidad y la reelección la
reelección para poder ser elegidos ellos
y postular nuevamente y la bicameralidad
para en el caso de que no se apruebe la
reelección poder postular a la nueva
segunda cámara a la nueva primera cámara
cinco años más y a la nueva segunda
cámara otros cinco años más entonces hay
una mezquindad de la clase política que
es la que ha originado estas grietas
desde el año dos mil uno hasta el día de
hoy los políticos y nuestra clase
política piensa es intereses
particulares inmediatos no piensan en el
país esa de la crisis en el Perú
antes de analizar la la situación de las
regiones peruanas quiero que hablemos de
las marchas de los ciudadanos que están
saliendo a manifestarse Elizabeth hay
también
informes en la prensa internacional y
allí en Perú de Quiénes están convocando
a estas movilizaciones ciudadanas en el
sur del país no son solamente grupos de
trabajadores
profesores o algunos sectores de la
clase Obrera peruana también se habla de
grandes movilizaciones financiadas por
la minería ilegal y por algunos sectores
bastante oscuros a nivel económico como
el narcotráfico y otros agentes que
buscan pues sembrar el miedo allí en
Perú qué tan cierto es esto
Bueno definitivamente tanto la dirección
Nacional de inteligencia como la Policía
Nacional está así dando diversas
informaciones sobre lo que se ha venido
investigando qué hay detrás de todas
estas movilizaciones que es algo
objetivo y lógico decir que se necesita
financiamiento porque en realidad para
el traslado la cobertura del de los
alojamientos
y la y la y también en muchos de estos
grupos violentos tienen armas hechizas
tienen también municiones y eso también
ha sido constatado por la policía
entonces hay que todavía profundizar más
en las investigaciones Y definitivamente
al parecer si hay una conexión entre lo
que ha sido la injerencia o lo que viene
siendo la injerencia de Evo Morales y
sus operadores políticos en regiones
Como por ejemplo uno cusco no olvidemos
que este señor se ha venido comiendo se
ha venido reuniendo en base Pues a una
agenda digamos política que inició con
el gobierno de Martín vizcarra para por
ejemplo el tema de la de la transición
del gas y se ha reunido con estos
gobernadores gobernadores que han
purgado condena en cárcel por delitos de
corrupción eso también hay que decirlo
no y uno de ellos Está también por el
aymarazo Entonces no hay que no hay que
olvidar también estas conexiones y no
hay que también subestimarlas porque
también escucho del otro lado cómo es
posible que crean que estamos siendo
financiados no es que sí existe esto y y
te lo vuelvo a repetir Yo escucho radios
locales regionales en las plataformas de
web existen estas transmisiones los Live
que están también en tiktok por ejemplo
las redes sociales y ahí te muestran la
realidad que a veces nosotros no
queremos ver claro yo creo que si bien
es cierto en el contexto jurídico
podemos hablar de delitos de matanzas de
de de de de de de de de de de de de
genocidios etcétera lo que en este
momento toca es exigir al a las a las
instituciones del estado investigar
exigir a la Policía Nacional uso
proporcional de la fuerza exigir que nos
garanticen también la seguridad no
solamente los que protestan también a
los que no protestan claro también
existe porque también hay ciudadanos
peruanos que han muerto en las
carreteras que han estado bloqueadas hay
recién nacidos madres gestantes adultos
mayores también hay que pensar en ellos
me parece a mí claro esta situación nos
obliga a razonar y reflexionar Más allá
de lo político que nos quieren vender no
algunos sectores claro la crisis hay que
abordarla desde todas las aristas
posibles finalmente todos los peruanos
están viendo afectados por esta por esta
crisis política y social allí pero pues
quedan Ya solo un par de minutos para
finalizar el programa quiero finalizar
entonces
viendo ese esa problemática que se vive
entre lima y las regiones esa
desconexión entre los grandes
empresarios los grupos económicos que
viven en Lima que se han enriquecido a
partir del establecimiento de la
democracia en Perú y esas regiones de
del interior del país que siguen
teniendo muchos problemas incluso para
comunicarse por vía terrestre por vía
aérea con Los Grandes centros urbanos de
este país esto también puede ser una
base de ese descontento expliquémoslo a
la audiencia fuera de las fronteras
peruanas comienzo con Omar muy puntual
por favor porque me quedan pocos minutos
es fundamental es una explicación
fundamental le pongo le pongo un ejemplo
hay heridos que se que han estecido
Víctimas de estos eh hechos lamentables
que para atenderlos se les ha tenido que
transportar a Lima o sea Lima sigue
siendo el centro de la salud importante
del Perú un herido un enfermo grave
tiene que ir a Lima desde madre de Dios
desde del cusco eso enardece a la gente
del sur andino esa discriminación en ese
contexto
sin cincuenta Muertos del sur andino
causados por la ineptitud del gobierno
es lo que ha hecho explosionar el ánimo
de la gente y sin duda Hay
financiamientos y tendrá el gobierno que
establecer si son financiamientos sanos
o criminales esa es otra cosa pero la
indignación porque se produjeron las
muertes de
cincuenta pobladores del sur andino y no
ha pasado nada en términos políticos es
lo que está despertando esta reacción
que ojalá mañana no conduzca ninguna
tragedia y Elizabeth su cierre sobre
esta situación de las zonas del interior
del país
Bueno definitivamente la contraloría
general de la república siempre nos
informa a nosotros de cómo va la
ejecución de gasto en la en las regiones
de nuestro país justamente las regiones
que hoy en día están convulsionadas son
las que tienen pues una ejecución de
gasto eficiente y están asoladas por la
corrupción no es posible que puno cusco
cierre el período anual con menos de 40%
de ejecución y esto se ve también en los
gastos que ellos realizan en la falta de
horas de infraestructura ciertamente lo
que señala el doctor Cairo es verdad no
definitivamente para atender a un herido
de bala a una o a cualquier persona que
requiera de una operación de urgencia
tiene que ser trasladado a Lima o alguna
provincia centralista que
brinde estos servicios Y definitivamente
Aquí hay una brecha por eso es mi
insistencia en que aquellos que vienen a
protestar de manera pacífica y legítima
no son aquellos que te piden una
asamblea como Constituyente como una
salida o de boluarte como una salida o
una respuesta inmediata detrás de todo
esto hay una demanda genuina que sí nos
podemos demorar de repente cinco diez
años superará este gobierno pero es
importante que boluarte tenga el inicio
del diálogo Pues con estas palabras
finalizamos el programa No cerramos con
la habitual conclusión de lo que pueda
suceder porque esta crisis está en
desarrollo y los acontecimientos pueden
cambiar de la noche a la mañana allí en
Perú le agradezco a Elizabeth Omar estar
con nosotros para vernos puesto en
perspectivas este análisis de la
situación allí en Perú es todo por hoy
En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos su sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y la producción de invitados a
cargo de Tania Herrera siga con nosotros
siga con France 24
[Música]